a breakaway group of migrants from the
caravan moving through Guatemala has
reportedly reached the border with
Mexico this comes just hours after
president trunk threatened to send in
the military to secure the border
if the migrants aren't stopped the
president blaming Democrats for the new
crisis on Twitter claiming their support
of weak immigration laws is making the
situation worse meanwhile Nancy Pelosi
is putting her foot down saying her
party isn't planning on working with
President Trump oh she says I'm sorry I
don't see any of us voting for wall
funding we have a responsibility to
secure our borders there are ways to do
that that are consistent with
civilization humanitarianism and who we
are as a nation we have to remove all
doubt about that
and with only 19 days to go until the
midterms and new Fox News poll shows was
extremely important to voters 46 percent
say it's immigration I just want to show
this other poll the Fox News pulled with
vote preference among those saying that
border security is extremely important
the Republican candidate at 58% the
Democratic candidate at 35 percent and
with this new Caravan Jessi moving its
way north 19 days before the election
not good timing for Democrats no I mean
it really visually it has a big impact
on voters when they see this it's not a
theoretical problem and it's just not
this one caravan we're talking about I
mean in terms of size caravans like this
are coming across the border all day
every day and there's really not a lot
we can do about it because a lot of
these loopholes are baked into our
immigration and Asylum system I mean it
used to be adult male Mexicans crossing
the border and now it's mostly families
and teenagers from Guatemala and from
Honduras and we can't turn them back we
can Mexicans you could Mexicans you
could but you have to bring in and take
when you apprehend them in to the rest
of the country and they're all claiming
credible fear now credible fear that
excuse has spiked over the last couple
of years yet when they use it the
economy in Honduras is going up yet
crime in Honduras is going down so it
makes me believe that these people are
being coached and you're hearing things
like NGOs
being activists and lawyers down to
Central American countries and they're
helping them with the care event they're
coaching them what to say when they get
to the border and it's interesting where
do they get the cameras from you know
we're hearing a lot of these NGOs are
bringing these camera crews in then all
of a sudden the people get off the van
they walk when the camera crews come out
the camera crews stop recording then
they hop back in the van then once they
get to Mexico they pay the drug cartels
and the smugglers $5,000 per family unit
to get him across the drug cartels are
the only ones making any money in this
process the drug cartels and the open
border Democrats they are on the same
side these drug cartels have made two
point five billion dollars in smuggling
alone per year that's on top of the drug
profits and that's a lot of money so we
have to change the immigration laws so
that you treat people that cross the
border if you're from Central America
the same way you do it is you're from
Canada and Mexico and Kennedy the other
thing is in these caravans what the
Department of Homeland Security is
reporting that the number of sexual
assaults happening along this route and
not just oh and the caravan is just he
was saying about 1600 migrants try to
cross the border a day they're finding
repeated incidents of sexual assault for
children even I mean this is happening
across the board
yeah that's horrible I mean we saw some
of that unfortunately in the shelters in
the aftermath of Hurricane Florence and
it's you know an unfortunate aspect of
human nature and you know we have to
find a way to let really good people
into the country and keep really bad
people like that out of the country the
government hasn't sufficiently done that
and I think part of this rests on
Congress because we've got a very
confusing immigration system and
Democrats and Republicans I'm convinced
this is the one issue where they will
never work together but it's interesting
because they have a president who
actually even though he's a hardliner
hardliner rhetorically on immigration I
think there's a lot that he would give
to Democrats in order to come up with a
compromise and I don't think you would
see that with the Obama administration
and Republicans in the same way or with
past Republican administrations so they
need to fix that and if you think about
the kind of people you want to have in
this country you want people who are
hardworking people who are ethical
people who look out for their families
and their communities and people who are
very physically strong so I think we
need to sit
an American Ninja Warrior obstacle
course
at the border and whoever can can make
it can't fake it they get through the
other thing is the United States is one
and trying to help those countries with
aid also helping in the criminal justice
system crime actually going down in
Honduras and Guatemala and yet the
caravan still comes well I think it's
economic problems that lead families to
decide that their best prospect is to
come toward the United States and as we
know their economies have been suffering
so I think that's the principal reason
but I'm interested in this as a
political ploy by Republicans because
clearly immigration is not a big issue
in this campaign according to the polls
i wing like seven percent of people say
it's a big issue the number one issue is
health care and you know at yeah poll
that Dana just showed it was number four
on the list no that's among extreme
people who are extremely everyone okay
okay so it's it's not the big issue is
health care and then you start looking
and you know the secondary issue is
reigning in President Trump and the
third one is people who want Democrats
to control the House of Representatives
those are the big issues in this issue
in particularly though because we're
gonna have time to talk about those
other issues today but what about you
Nancy Pelosi saying that they won't work
with President Trump right to me is not
a right-left issue you have a
humanitarian crisis with children being
sent to the hospital as they have to
stop at these weigh stations they're
dehydrated some have been victims of
sexual assault there if they get here we
could it that well it's not true I said
not good I know it's not good
so why would an see Pelosi already be
signaling that this is an important
correction because it wasn't extreme
voters it was actually a poll of likely
voters no no people who are extremely
conservative oke preference among those
who say that border security is most
important they would prefer that smell
okay so what I think you have to
understand is the Nancy Pelosi is
talking about the waldina and about the
president's persistence I think
yesterday member we quoted her saying it
was a manhood issue for him
it's a political issue he sees that as a
promise he made to his base that he
wants to deliver for his base but if you
go back in time
remember going back to the President
Bush collimated President Obama you had
Republicans and Democrats working on the
immigration issue working on border
security but Trump has made it all about
the wall and what Nancy Pelosi is saying
hey this is not about the was not a good
expense of money or time and certainly
not to me let's get Greg in here because
one other things an see Pelosi says and
you hear this from Democrats a lot is
this is not who we are as a nation
yeah it's a cop-out it's it's actually
disgusting what happened to the
Democratic Party as one said Bill
Clinton President Obama understood that
border security helps define a country
and like it or not wall the wall is
actually part of border security how
could it not be
we have fences we have a president
that's interested in putting out a wall
that what putting up a wall again like I
said before if you're on Safari and
you're being chased by a rhino you hop
into the first truck you see you don't
wait for the fourth truck so there's a
huge dishonesty going on with the media
here when they will willfully ignore the
land between Honduras and Guatemala and
the United States imagine how many lives
would be saved and how many rapes would
be prevented if they actually were able
to stop once they leave their country
and and lay claim to some land there
rather than having to risk their lives
making it to our border that is a huge
hypocrisy that somehow we are we are
encouraging people to make this terrible
terrible journey before some kind of
political optics and I hate using the
word optics lastly to your point you
know where is the me tube movement like
if you're if we're all you aren't
putting women in danger for this issue
this issue where are you how can you how
can you allow this to happen it's that's
actually pretty disgusting well I think
but you raised a really good point about
Mexico and that's one of the things if
you take some of the hyperbole and
rhetoric out of it and you look at what
the president is saying he's appealing
to Mexico you know aside from
threatening to shut down the southern
border but they do have some
responsibility here and they do open up
both borders in order to send people
further north so if it is a humanitarian
issue and Mexico is a humanitarian
country with people who care very much
about their
and neighbors to the north and south
then why don't they have better systems
in place to absorb some of the refugees
the other lies is that economic problems
make your life it puts your life in
threat it's like no it's like you could
stay in the country and deal with these
economic problems well you know what we
have a history in America people from
Cuba getting on the high seas their
lives we have people country wherever
there's leftism that's where people are
in danger all I'm saying is there's a
history of people putting themselves at
great risk in order to reach our shores
because they believe in America they
like the funny something in between here
and there no but I'm saying it's not it
believe me we have a better stronger
economy than Mexico you can
you now have an a menu of options you
know I'm telling you that's what
families are focused on is the I think
they're really focused on their children
great they want the great something
Jesse said we're just up for our last
word and that is that the drug cartels
apparently there's not a single person
that has come across the border that
hasn't had to pay some sort of money as
a family or as an individual to the drug
cartels and perhaps there's something
there that you could find a bipartisan
agreement on figure out a way to target
those drug cartels those leaders and
their finances and shut them down I mean
they're making fistfuls of cash every
day from these smuggling operations on
top of the profits they're making from
heroin cocaine and marijuana and the
Democrats have to understand the
position they're in by having open
borders policies only empowers the drug
cartels it empowers no one else only the
drug cartels and I'm happy that one
would admit that the Trump economy is so
strong people are risking their lives
that come to America to get a piece of
the I say I said the American I come
by the way I don't understand what you
just said you know I don't I don't get
it you know you act as if there's
nothing here that would attract people
what I think a wall would prevent the
drug cartels a walk I think so from
smuggler